yeah hello and welcome to new Rapids
game on each I'm going to play Petrovsky
and I'm actually underdog in this match
but not by much but by a couple of
points and d4 Bishop f4 is played in
London system repair d5 shows some
ambition this and c5 and b5 is one of
the more one of the more ambitious lines
let's see what Petrovsky is going to do
I'm not quite sure what is best here a
four and that's one of the moves I think
we should be to b7 this what's normally
actually oh just put pressure on this
takes then Knight takes
c4 is interesting I can do a couple of
things here just taking as possible
Knight takes c6
[Music]
you can also cheap it can take on c4 on
between a shire is also an option
yeah but the idea is that after 93 I can
play deform and win some time he goes
with this and now I go before again and
he has this this development clocked up
this is a very this is very comparable
to the declined banker with 93
yeah like for 93 Bishop d7 a4 against
them decline yeah it's very similar yeah
I think white should probably play Queen
c2 here to have a thief already if it
doesn't do that I might play a six and
force them to take so I think in c2 now
looks logical so that II 6 can be
answered with the form it's really not
the only move but it makes sense
No so we 634 as I don't know I don't
really want to want to want that to
happen what is interesting here compared
to the the banco proper is that the
night is not on f3 so it is may be
possible to um to go for f4 e 64 maybe I
should do this immediately go for that
blocked centre day let's let's do that
that makes f1 far less attractive if you
if I would have gone v6 g6 maybe you
find f4 is really an option it's it
would have been very ambitious of course
but this is interesting
that is typically is to get this close
center and with the queenside being
closed there's nothing to worry on that
part of the board so I can maybe play on
the King side with g6 move the died at
five and is this thing so is he going to
play at four
maybe the Queen has to move anyway
long term I just wonder to da Don I
don't when you believe in FY such as
slowish move and maybe still Queen c7
would have prevented the idea all
together the fianchetto is is a very
sensible way to develop him it has this
it keeps f4 as an option so here I can
do couple of things I can try to develop
the Bishop e7 with g6 on an entirely
different option would be h5m trying to
play H form
I think I'm going to think a word
so the left f4 I have this long diagonal
this idea after capturing maybe h4 h5
something that I should have considered
after 92l because after h5 9 f3 stops h4
I'm still doing this I think it is
helpful
now f4 is not so attractive due to age
form
I have not Castle short yet so I can
actually cancel long just put the King
on to be a tour a a tour so it would be
fairly safe you still have set clocked
up development here the knight cannot
move and so on okay to a3 of it
yeah h3 is looking very looks like very
standard reply and then after h4g for
everything is closed
that's is surprising it looks like
something that I've done Adam helped it
helps me
it's very strange why would you allow me
that pawn takes Knight X is definitely
good and the f5 is also strange huh yeah
but this is just just very fine for me
okay I am taking here and open the H
file
yeah Bishop h6 comes into consideration
simply trading this now getting rid of
this Bishop is helpful now g4 is also an
option after Bishop h6 takes takes Queen
d2 wears a bit with annoying
I don't want twin g5 to happen
yeah but we're just all casual to
scooter just put it here and then for
this white this is a great idea here
after Bishop g5 I can still play Bishop
h6
not shown one thing I have to watch out
for is when I move the Queen that a five
is coming and potentially create form
it's something that I should not allow
so if nothing yeah what I tried to say
is if nothing special happens Idol King
be a juke GA Bishop see 18 years put
everything over to the Kings side and
win down turned me nice his pieces are
really not great
yeah it's something that I was just
spotting him as a potential idea not to
be 3-wood
yeah I want to play this anyhow let
Bishop sucks on g7 I traded against his
good Bishop no makes perfect sense
maybe book g8 was more precise actually
so that night d3 Queen d8 why it should
matter shouldn't matter all that much
now after taking a look takes Queen d2
I'm ready for Luke h8 simply doubling
another doubling of the books actually
doesn't do all that much
it's nice Sampat but immediately
crushing or anything okay so I just
recapture
and I think he probably has to take on
age six and 92 and try to simply simply
try to hang on and defenders so Group F
8 is probably the most natural move and
still reasonably solid
yes finally getting getting this out
so how to do it can think about doubling
on I wonder about the queen with the
best way to use the queen is in
desperation to DA Don on the same rank
Knight a5 has also moved that I should
not totally ignore I mean something like
King b8 Bishop c8 move the Queen the SEC
Knight a5 96 coming
and it is not so easy this this whole
position this is a members are tougher
than I thought I really overestimated
this a little bit I mean I'm happy with
this position but I was really thinking
why does this is it absolutely terrible
shape but it's not so bad
Queen da does a couple of things I want
to sometimes bring over to h8 or g5 and
another IDM is that I'm clearing c7 for
the King and then Bishop c8 yeah this is
something that I had on the radar night
H for coming
yeah we'll have night h5 as we could
move here taking the pawn
now g-49 h form that is probably not
super promising oh yeah let's play this
maybe Queen d2 is good
and I cling to and stupid I want a
stupid mistake
95 is a thing after that
[Music]
or this one is the same idea
all right what a stupid mistake it was
really really stupid to play this
yeah I support this really really good
position
I know white is okay extremely terrible
now he's okay now it's got Bishop page
three all of a sudden and so on I'm such
a [ __ ] and our plate is too superficial
and it's not much too superficial way
thinking that everything is good but
it's that one in the case
probably this Bishop h6 business was too
too quick either that I didn't really
have one diretor
okay you should age 3m wouldn't move and
96's also in
Queen f6 Queen h6
net so it's uncomfortable
[Music]
we should bring this nights back up that
is really not good on age five put it to
a six for example has much better
looking at the e4 pawn of course I would
like to trade this so it's the threat
don't don't see anything at the moment I
keep you under attack and maybe I can
get in and overnight h7f a dose of it
then Queen to e7 zone not so easy to get
rid of this this pest on you six
once the play 94 it seems Queen f7 94
okay oh this is useful anyway now 94 is
probably wrong in a take and play night
of aid right isn't that it's not totally
clear
maybe he plays Knight f3 h 4m just yeah
but okay currently four is hanging so
that is not such an easy plan now make
sense I can't move this Queen f7 runs
into 98
what about Queen h7 for Queen h5 it's
got 92 d8 but I'm not sure how dangerous
that is
hmm yeah every bit a bit terrible hair
that I'm in this position after the way
the opening went but it was totally
one-sided so he says he can sacrifice a
form which is maybe true 94 Queen da da
and Queen c7 is strong now
hmm yeah I'm basically lost after I take
you for
how do I take probably with this now is
that way to untangle here the threatens
is for and on g4 and I take the light
net FG 5 maybe
Oh tough probably not fg5 maybe I just
take it in and play for the blockade you
ever take it pawn takes 90-87
this kind of thing okay but if I check
check on jaywalking of three check on h2
this is probably a draw there's probably
a draw okay that's maybe a tad risky but
it just takes with the night I didn't
expect that not that it's necessarily
bad it's just that I didn't have it on
the radar okay I would like to approach
with the King for Shuang right offers a
draw
no not really
so here king of three I mean I can force
a draw quite obviously of it and I still
want to try and maybe this is not
realistic I can try to put a knight on
to a five and try to promote
if I just do this you have a knight to
f6 Knight b6 is also attracting me here
because I threatened to take and play b3
which is close to promotion
no that's actually wrong hmm
96 and night f8 comes and I don't think
I can take yet take on c4 takes b3 now I
can actually take Knight b6 threatens to
capture it really does takes takes b3
Bishop f moly - Bishop d3 ok so I can
you can do the same okay
[Music]
that is the tetris key to places to play
like I do it him
so cannot activate the king now which is
well which is a problem you will
probably not take I'm not threatening to
take anyway I had Soviet move actually
it can take we just take this is
actually good news at least now I'm in a
situation where I cannot go loose
anymore I am maybe I cannot win but I
can also not lose anymore
so question is do I play the a g5 is a
draw this is probably more interesting
we should have seven losses and if I'm a
g5 here here I think he cannot take my
pawn that easily anymore to do this
first
but now itself trapped is Bishop
yourself trapped it so now I can go over
here
the question is now it exists no this
falling apart now now yeah I shouldn't
win this and certainly the ending was no
big issue for him actually
you're the tough game a really tough
game yeah I'm not happy how I played it
out right out of the opening because I
felt it was really comfortable like when
we got this and a little bit later yeah
this is certainly fine everything so top
this up and age five and he didn't react
to that and 4-h will not be really nice
for black oh and five and now now here's
he are the things where we can I improve
I cancelled long and ninety-four is
given by the comb now to move that ahead
on the way down
yeah that is good yeah it really is good
he cannot go f6 and he cannot we cannot
really do all that much yeah it makes
sense
also this and Bishop c8 coming
[Music]
yes he said he suffered most of the time
but I think you see that won't that won
the case anymore later so the way I play
it was probably not great yeah this the
engine still lost my position but I must
have done something stupid here top
Queen to d8 93 from maybe 9 h5 was
rubbish
I mean Oh engine on simply G time talk
about the move that I did not see at all
g5 Lajo
it's not a very human continuation
and here it seems I'm okay but as tough
to find out and here but white is better
it may be if we believe the computer
graph like here in the analysis and it
says to breathe analysis and there it
seems that there wasn't anything so
obvious and now I have to defend it's
not funny you should have three more
stronger food air prevents twin h5 that
sets true that's true
yeah that makes sense and Bishop f3 if
it happen to I do one I'm really
suffering him computer gives qb7 lipid
great my Wireless should slowly
improving
now that's probably the the momentum
after the green trade I still felt and
suffering a little bit bit 90s 97 yeah
of course 94 the draw which I saw but I
wanted to it was a bit of a gamble maybe
but what could what was the thing
King f3 king of 344 yeah he's coming
this next room
g4 said really a threat
I mean some some positions might be a
draw due to fortress-like I mean blood
the end of this giving here is that
really that terrible bishops I don't get
them and I don't get that if I can't
play like okay this is just not it's not
working of it he takes on d7 of course
and I'm blundering a piece but this is
something like this could be a draw yeah
okay he's got Bishop f5 in yeah the
should've button if my king is only
seven and many if sent but there are
some tries for fortresses which prom did
not very successful ones yeah try I mean
I kind of knew that I had to take the
draw that I wanted to I didn't want to
he took I think that this was helping me
a little bit the engine doesn't see it
as a mistake because well the thinks the
position is equal anyway which is true
but it is still helping me because it
makes my life a little bit um yeah yeah
I know I cannot lose their pawn to g5 is
a focus
let's probably draw up to this point
here I don't think you can draw anymore
cable and appointment so here I cannot
just win the pawn that is a draw it's
totally closed and pistols this end it's
a draw but I can just play here and here
oops he stuck to this is a problem this
King here King g5 and but if you go here
and I'm getting over here and win this
stuff the bishop is just on the wrong
side of the board basically if it would
be like here within his camp we can
maybe cover everything but here you just
drop drop the pawns yeah I'd have the
NuvaRing game he had this Bishop f3 idea
and one point to prevent my Queen age 5
it was probably the key moment here when
I when I decided to gamble on and he had
he had